and good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin with new details in
the case of the self-proclaimed apostle
the leader of a church that claims some
five million members in the United
States in more than 50 other countries
around the world
natan joaquin garcia was arrested over
the summer and charged by the California
Attorney General with 27 felony counts
sex trafficking and the production of
child pornography he has pleaded not
guilty and today in Los Angeles
prosecutors began to lay out their case
against a man who tells his followers he
is the only person on earth who speaks
to God the day began in Los Angeles as
prosecutors turned over to his lawyers a
disc with some of the sex videos they
say they found on the apostles
electronic devices
there's devices that have content that
we've identified as child pornography
what we've done with those is we've
provided defense with a a like a PDF
file of the metadata in the everything
but the photos and videos and that we've
made the photos videos available to them
to review which they've been doing since
Monday there's also a group of devices
that have what our experts refer to as
age difficult images where there is
breast development but the girls look
quite young so we are not at this
juncture in a position to say with
absolute certainty these are 18 or 19
year olds rather than 15 16 or 17 year
olds no those are separate because child
pornography needs we've identified them
with certainty as being under a teenage
difficult means we have not been able to
confirm their identities yet but we have
some concern based on the nature of the
case and the other devices where we have
confirmed it that they may be minors so
without further due diligence we didn't
want to simply copy the images and
provide them rather those also we
handled those the same way as a child
pornography
correct that's not really compliant and
so it's a little it's a little
misleading to suggest on this very
beautifully done spreadsheet that all
the yes boxes means that we have all the
data we have exactly nothing
we have nothing well I don't think
that's quite true I think there's a
little bit of data that we do have and
all that mr. Mason explain what that is
lawyers for Garcia claiming they're not
getting all the evidence they want
executive producer Rhonda Swartz is in
Los Angeles today to cover the court
hearing and joins us now from outside
the courthouse Ron did seem like a
contentious hearing between the
prosecutors from the attorney general's
office and Garcia's own lawyers
it was indeed and used as you can see
the man knows in his followers as the
Apostle is in his orange jumpsuit having
traded in his tuxedo and surrounded by
his lawyers today they argued that the
defense has been slow to turn over
critical pieces of electronic evidence
that was seized in a raid of his
properties the key witnesses in this
case are known as jane doe's one through
four but what facts their story up is
this physical evidence that the
prosecution claims they have and these
videos it's cell phones computers we
don't really know the full extent it's
only been described as 50 electronic
devices
apparently contain videos of the sex
acts themselves that he's been charged
with with underage girls including
forcible rape of a minor and of course
in filing papers by the Attorney
General's Office they said at one point
he had the young girls put whipped cream
on each other and then lick it off a
sort of a very offensive if true also in
the courtroom Rhonda we see a couple of
women who are charged with him what's
the story with them well if you saw it
in the courtroom today two of this four
women three women excuse me who've been
charged with his accomplices these are
young women who have been in the inner
circle of the church who are charged
with effectively as of the Jeffrey
Epstein case recruiting these underage
minors they were in the court filing the
Attorney General says
that they recruited miners and have them
dressed provocatively like schoolgirls
they had them put whipped cream on each
other and they described various sex
acts that they seem to have on the
videotape recordings that they have so
one of the women is still at large but
Susana Oaxaca was in the court today and
I spoke to her briefly she was she's
released on house arrest she has was
surrounded by attorneys wouldn't say
anything very polite shook my hand quiet
throughout neither of the women had
anything to say Rhonda Schwartz thanks
very much outside the courthouse in Los
Angeles stay on the story all of this is
being closely watched by a group of
former members of the Apostles church
who have banded together in an effort to
expose what they claim is its corruption
greed and sexual depravity Raquel Guerra
was 14 years old and living in Texas
when she was told by her church that she
had to marry her boyfriend because they
had had sex
they had fornicated her pastor told her
I kind of felt like there wasn't really
a choice because you're kind of scared
because you're kind of scared of
actually going to hell because they
really really put that in your head and
she says it became a marriage marked by
physical abuse and heartbreak with the
church indifferent to her plight maybe
it's something that I'm doing to pray to
God maybe to change my ways that maybe
I'm provoking this in some way and now
former members of the church have begun
to organize using social media including
this site on reddit a public effort to
expose what they say is the corrupt
hypocritical and immoral leadership of
Joaquin Garcia and his worldwide church
she's demented he he's not right in the
head
he thinks he's not only an apostle but
he thinks he's the Living Christ on this
earth when he speaks to his congregation
he literally when he walks through his
walkway he says you have not received me
as only as an apostle of Christ you have
received me as Jesus
christ himself the church spends huge
sums on its apostle with elaborate
birthday party celebrations this church
in Oregon close to the big public
happy birthday video the church has
built a private zoo and rents for the
Apostle in Texas and even as he was
behind bars in California his daughter
was married in an over-the-top wedding
in California to the dismay of many
former members because I know how hard
the church members try to give as much
as they can they go without to be
blessed to give such a big offering and
them to do things of this nature with
their hard-earned money the church
insistence leader the Apostle is
innocent of any wrongdoing and it has
told its followers to pray for joaquin
garcia to be found not guilty church
leaders have also told members to shun
to ignore those who speak out against it
without their motto
even if it were your brother your father
your mother avoid speaking to them their
word in a way like angry murmurs it is
very dangerous to speak with those
people nautica recognizes personas the
way works in the church is if you're not
with them you're against them the way it
works that what they preach is if you
are deviating from the path of the Lord
you're you're from the devil now the
devil has gotten you the devil has done
everything he could with you so your
conversations you you're pretty much
meaningless raquel guerra says she had
to leave the church once she sought a
divorce from her husband causing strains
with her family I mean we do talk of
course but I really don't have a really
close relationship with my family and
especially probably after this I we're
gonna be surprised if I'm I'm disowned
because you're talking with us right now
yes that would be seen as a sin oh it's
worse than a sin it's going against the
man of God you're it's beyond a sin and
why even go ahead sorry yeah and so why
are you doing it because I'm tired of
seeing my family just deceived they
ready they really don't see it as much
as you try and tell them show them facts
they they refuse to even consider that
this could be a cult again the apostle
joaquin garcia has denied all of the
allegations against him we asked his
lawyers and church representatives to be
here tonight on our program but they
declined the offer remains open as we
continue to investigate this important
story